[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue à cette édition
d' espace autochtone en direct en direct
avec un peu de retard on a eu des petits
soucis techniques mais là tout le monde
est en poste tout le monde entend tout
le monde tout le monde ne voit pas tout
le monde allez comprendre pourquoi parce
que notre invité il est à sept-îles dans
un studio alors lui ne nous voit pas
mais nous on le voit et vous allez le
voir aussi c'est le chef jean-charles
piétacho chef de la communauté
d'ekuanitshit bonjour ekoué chef
piétacho poteau je suis évidemment en
compagnie d'isabelle picard alors je
voulais saluer le chef
oui bonjour bonjour anne marie bonjour
sans tarder
quoi quoi quoi je suis content de vous
avoir à même cas que moi voilà parfait
donc en même temps ça me rassure parce
que le chef vous entends aussi isabelle
donc tout est sous contrôle a là on va
pouvoir faire cette émission une
émission qui va être consacré au rôle au
rôle pas toujours facile d'ailleurs d'un
chef dans d'un conseil de bande d'une
communauté autochtone alors peut-être
qu'on pourrait commencer parce qu'il ya
des gens qui nous écoutent vous savez
dans les communautés autochtones mais
également il ya des beaucoup de non
autochtone qui nous écoutent il ya
beaucoup de gens à l'international qui
nous écoutent aussi alors ce serait
intéressant d'abord d'expliquer je vais
le faire avec vous chef piétacho c'est
quoi un conseil de bande m'écouter c'est
un créatures fédéral qui a été décidé
dans
année où la loi sur les indiens a été
fondé et depuis ce temps là on connaît
le système fédéral qui est régie
nos vies dans nos communautés j'utilise
le mot communauté et depuis ce temps là
il ya des
chef et conseiller qui sont nommés d'un
conseil depuis de piste alors et pour ce
qui est de certaines communautés comme
la nôtre là le système
vraiment est établi dans les années 1963
donc nous ce système n'a pas été
immédiat lors de la création de la loi
et
j'ai c'est sûr que j'ai beaucoup de
choses à dire sur le système donc entre
1876 et la création de votre conseil de
bande dans votre communauté à vous
spécifiquement il s'est passé quoi entre
ces deux périodes là écoutez contenu il
ya comme le la 20ème à le contacter
le précompte ac et nous nous étions des
sociétés organisées
donc nous le la nation d'où je viens ce
une nation qui étaient nomades qui
parcourait le grain territoire de nita
sinan qui avait aucun aucune frontière
et pendant de longues longues périodes
on l'a fait
puis on a continué jusqu'à pour la
communauté que je représente dans les
années ce sans détour mais il ya eu des
décisions fédérales se sont prises à 20
68 ans que je vois sur ma avoir
l'occasion de se piquer aussi alors vous
êtes un minou de la communauté
d'ekuanitshit equani cheat c'est ce
qu'on appelait avant mingant dont vous
êtes sur la basse côte nord
je sais plus et c'est là qu'on tenons
bascou tenons là encore on est on est
entre mettant ses ciels et
havre-saint-pierre et natashquan mettant
ouais tiens pour expliquer combien temps
ça vous a pris à partir de votre
communauté pour venir jusqu'à sept îles
c'est environ deux heures en voiture là
c'est généralement soit le temps que ça
prend pas pour me rendre disponible pour
aujourd'hui
bon ça nous explique bien donc ou est-ce
que vous êtes c'est quand même assez
loin
vous êtes un chef est-ce que c'est
comparable à un poste de maire dans une
municipalité parce qu'en fait vous gérez
votre communauté c'est un peu quand même
un maire qui gère son village ou sa
communauté mais je dis est ce que mais
non en fait ce n'est pas du tout la même
chose votre votre tâche est beaucoup
plus complexe que la tâche du maire
d'une municipalité
oui avec ce qui nous est dévolue
annuellement ben écoutez en or
l'administration là qui gère l'éducation
dans la communauté
la santé tout ce qui est infrastructure
on peut parler de logement ici
et puis aussi des projets 40 à chaque
année qui peuvent venir de d'autres
sources de financement ça c'est
l'équivalent pour ma communauté auquel
je représente la c1 me rend plus de 10
millions le fonds qui provient du
fédéral 10 millions qui proviennent de
finir oui communauté donc vous êtes en
relation avec le gouvernement fédéral
mais est ce que vous êtes en relation
avec le gouvernement provincial est ce
que vous êtes en communication avec eux
la bête définitivement vous savez à
cause du système
nos relations sont surtout au niveau
fédéral et depuis quelques années il ya
comme une ouverture avec la province de
québec d'un certain programme mais
certains dossiers et mais non je pense
que la majorité de nos relations sont
avec le fédéral d'accord alors vous avez
donc lé conseil de bande existe à cause
de la loi sur les indiens
donc c'est une entité qui a été créée
par le gouvernement fédéral donc par des
non autochtones
et ça c'est pas évident ça ne plaît pas
à tout le monde
il y as souvent dans les communautés
autochtones des gens qui sont évidemment
contre le contre le gouvernement fédéral
contre la loi sur les indiens mais aussi
contre le conseil de bande
définitivement je pense que ça c'est pas
partager un totalité d'un
les membres look sens on peut appeler ça
des gens d'influencé qui connaît bien
l'histoire et d'ailleurs je fais partie
de ces gens là moi j'ai été auparavant
d'être leader dans la communauté
j'ai été directeur général dans la
communauté mais la première journée que
j'ai été élu en 1981 ans en septembre
1991 la première lettre que j'ai envoyée
aux autorités concernées pour un dossier
en particulier
j'ai signé mail est comme ce sillage un
char piétacho s l eau
et puis je m'affiche jean charles
piétacho chef selon la loi sur les
indiens
la plupart des leviers les choses oui
j'ai la plupart des gens m'ont dit mais
c'est pourquoi tu peux pas te vois-tu
mais celle est là et si les médecins les
avocats tout le monde a des lettres à la
poste mais moi je voulais spécifié déjà
j'apprécie le fait que je suis un lead a
choisi damas communauté selon notre lit
cela mais le mouche défini par une loi
fédérale
moi ça me préoccupe parce que moi depuis
de nombreuses années
moi on parle beaucoup de réédifié notre
nation et c'est pas évident lorsque vous
avez un système qui est là depuis au
delà de 200 ans et qui a fait
détruire nos systèmes qu'on avait pas ce
qu'on avait une propre système
ah ben on n'avait pas un chef on avait
des reader des leaders qui parcourut le
territoire qui se réunissait à un moment
donné dans l'année et ça c'est ce qui a
fait qu'aujourd'hui
est ce pour ça je vous disais tantôt
nous à ce point de chute
la communauté comme tel a été créée
sainement et accord non définitif en
1963 parce que dans les années 40 tué 50
il voulait qu'on soit quand ils
voulaient nous des ménages et des
fonctionnaires sont arrivés dans la
communauté à 10 un bain et a demandé la
première question qu'a demandé aux gens
qui étaient près de l'église a dit je
veux parler au chef le fonctionnel mais
là les aînés qui était l'oeuvre
nous sommes tous des chefs c'est que tu
veux bon c'est c'la yosi bayonne ils y
ont parlé que là avec une création d'une
communauté vous aurez peut-être des
services de mise en plis tout semble
aller les aînés leurs leaders ont refusé
carrément puis ils ont dit on va vous
amener à natashquan qui la communauté
venait de se créer dans les années 50 51
et à 48,49 à maliotenam il jambes au
sein de la communauté où les mêmes en
deux ceux qui ont de la famille à
natashquan ion en attachement à ce que
malines les eaux et moi aller à
maliotenam parce qu'on veut créer une
communauté les gens ont carrément refusé
le fédéral a menacé comme un exigeant
depuis la cession de la suite on la
connaît dans la communauté succès depuis
quarante huit à soixante deux tours on
n'avait pas les services que tout ce
qu'on nous faisait tous les conseils
avez là il y avait des maisons système
de santé éducation menoua equani site
pendant cette longue période résistance
d'affirmations les gens mais je remercie
toujours les aînés du talent qui ont
toujours dit nous nous avons un système
nous avons une façon de voir nous avons
une façon de de réaliser une au
territoire l'occupation territoire as
fait à partir de la communauté des
points et y est ça je pense est
historiquement les gens il faut qu'il
connaît ici c'est comme si nous on n'a
pas choisi le mois là j'ai pas choisi ce
système là c'est un système imposé
système colonial que tous on est des
fois je me sens comme le colonisé qui
devient colonisateur ça fait mal de dire
ça mais moi j'apprécie beaucoup mais
gens qui m'appuient depuis 80 ans
l'ida dans la communauté depuis 1991
mais ils savent ma pensée ma façon de
voir ma vision de voir que nous sommes
un peuple
nous faisons partie d'un peuple le
peuple innu et ça je pensais pour
reconnu parce que c'est remplacés par
des systèmes qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on
connaît ce que des divisions puis le
système social qu'on avait été ébranlée
sinon brisée puis là je vais pas faire
l'histoire on connaît l'histoire des
personnages on connaît tout ça moi je
suis un ex pensionnaire
mais sauf que c'est un peu un défi pour
un leader de dire à ces gens là oui un
système qui nous qui nous est imposée
oui oui nous avons des problèmes sociaux
oui nous devons faire du mieux qu'on
peut avec les ressources de donner des
chiffres t'entourent madras permet pas
décidé c'est quoi je dois faire sur la
santé le logement sur l'éducation
c'est tout est déjà décidé d'y planifier
par eux à ottawa puis 10 voici madame
tout le monde nous parle de santé
il dit allez allez faire du loisir on a
zéro refinancement l'oise et dans la
communauté on n'a même pas de haut
niveau des langues la culture il ya zéro
financement mais parce que il ya un
système qui est établie qui est là qui
le système provincial dans l'éducation
le système fédéral au niveau la santé
nous aussi on aimerait enfin ont réalisé
ce qui nous conviendrait le plus mais à
cause des règlements puis des règles
sont établies
alors quel pouvoir est-ce que vous avez
alors qu'est ce qu'il vous reste tout ce
qui me reste comme pouvoir c'est moi
c'est parce qu' on essaie d'aller au
delà des fois
ça de se sortir de ce système à travers
moi je pourrais appeler cela de se
prendre en mains de 10 rebonds t on et
le on a le pouvoir de face qui nous
convient dans la communauté même si on
sait les fois pénalisée là on prend des
décisions qui vont à l'encontre mais
vous savez comment ça marche un système
est en jeu je prends ces 1000 pour aider
des enfants aller dans le new team est
en territoire
l'année d'après le vérificateur arripe
il dit est de 5000 vous avez pas le
droit je veux retenir ce l'automne et
financières se sont madame c'est ça la
réalité auquel on doit faire face et
nous qui devons faire face aux décisions
puis à l'extérieur dans une assemblée
générale on n'a pas les fonctionnels qui
ont décidé le ce soir à ottawa québec
ils sont pas là c'est nous qui devons
faire face à ces demandes qui sont
agrandies sein d'un domaine juste d'un
domaine du logement à écouter on a parlé
de poudre le besoin de logement et au
delà de gym est juste la région du
québec j'ai étudié jamais le mot
province la légende du québec l'on se
sait des besoins criants puis ccd la
démographie dans une communauté nous
lasser tu peux y aller à travers le pays
la lv1 constante croissance mais là on
est stabilisé alors je pense que le coût
de la ville où les augmentations les
autres pôles ça fait des années et des
années
ce système y en a puisque comme on peut
pas avancer de pardon ce qu'est ce que
vous pensez des des chiffres de conseils
de bande qui exemple comme à pessamit
devons utiliser la voie des tribunaux
pour tenter de faire reconnaître
notamment leurs droits ou de répondre à
leurs propres besoins est ce que c'est
une voie à une option qui vous a marqué
importante mais moi je pense oui c'est
une voie qui peut être à utiliser mais
vous savez lorsqu'on voit devant les
tribunaux c'est tu donnes 25,1 de ta vie
ou 15 ans de ta vie tu as besoin de
l'avis de des aînés de plus en plus nos
aînés dans nos communautés là c'est l'un
des hauts lieux
vous savez comment ça marche sur les
eaux gens partent nos bibliothèques qui
partent c'est une voie qui peut être
utilisé soit administrativement au selon
politiquement le pour reconnaître le
titre aborigène au doigt mais ça une
fois après 25 ans je vais vous donner un
exemple de coordination en
colombie-britannique d'ailleurs ce salut
les gens là comme le britannique keane
qui n'ont pas peur d'aller devant les
tribunaux et ont gagné des causes au
delà de 20 cause au niveau national et
ayant beaucoup aussi perdu mais juste un
exemple on parle de ducey devant l'ot le
fédéral
la cour nous demande de prouver que nous
étions la nasa si c'est aberrant c'est
vraiment bien on nous demande là vous
étiez ou laquelle place à qu'elle vit
bien qu'elle ôte à tout seul avec un peu
plus de mal c'est difficile à expliquer
écouter c'est c'est comme une société et
puis c'est ce qui pore reconnu à esi
vous occupiez pas vous étiez pas l'homme
si tu comprend le système de nomadic
l'appui on est maintenant les comme
sédentaires mais ça nous fait mal ça
aussi mais hélas on dit mais là au
niveau fédéral il est juge par ci et
financiers comme tu veux aller à
l'encontre de d'un système mais les gens
de biche ils l'ont testé ayant gagné une
cause concernant le cheat aborigènes
mais à quoi elle est comme réduit au
lieu de ce territoire qui disons
signifie mais on se ramasse avec un
territoire qui aux plus grands ce que
nous on aurait pensé qu'on sait c'est
steam voit peut-être ce serait
administratif pour peut-être aussi faire
respecter
certains droits individuels ou
collectifs mais je vous dis simplement
la piste des coûts exorbitants le
fédéral paie pas les cours il va
peut-être donner un montant du débit
mais à la fin là c'est toi qui assume la
pi pour assumer ces coûts là ça veut
dire c'est un choix face et effets du
logement ont mis à les en course et
c'est même avec nos revenus
les fantômes ne peut pas se permettre ça
mais ça donne des choix déchirants et
c'est des choix dessinent à parce que le
côté social
nous nous exige aussi à répondre à des
situations très très on n'a pas la main
et une communauté nous autochtone
premières nations comme vous voulez
si on a fait cette émission à cette
semaine c'est à la suite d'une nouvelle
il ya un chef un chef micmac le chef de
listuguj en gaspésie qui a décidé de
démissionner et la raison qu'il donnait
c'est qu'ils vivaient de la violence
latéral dans sa communauté
qu'est ce que ça veut dire c'est quoi
qu'est ce qu'il a voulu nous dire
l'accès quel genre de violences est apte
et je sympathise avec le chef puis je
prenais la communauté qui dirige depuis
saint chef que j'apprécie beaucoup
d'ailleurs il parle français dont comme
moi tout comme le chef jacques martin
c'est comme choisir ta ta ta réponse à
des membres de 20 des demandes de
projets de logements
d'emploi et tout un plus au niveau
social et fléau de la drogue peu importe
le type de drogue qui n'offrait plat en
année les gens nous disent de prendre
des décisions puis des décisions souvent
cessé d intervention ce serait de
concert avec sécurité locale ou la
sûreté du québec mais il ya un événement
qui est animé par rapport à
l'histoire de drague d'intervention mais
c'est peut-être pas le seul ses six
départs depuis son mandat le kiwi mais
je vous dis je le connais là je connais
ça mais sauf que le contexte labour puis
le comté chez nous la cci c'est à peu
près la même voie sincèrement je le
comprends je comprends puis je prends
pas parce que nous on fait une
intervention au niveau de la drogue
aussi
et moi j'ai été menacé de mort ça le
deal
vandal non il nous a dit à quelqu'un je
vois le tirer parce que on a décidé dans
la communauté que cette personne là ne
viendrait plus pour de façon définitive
banni à vie et à trop ccc ya sol
williams et dans les communautés la
violence latéral elle vient aussi de
l'intérieur de la communauté passe à
l'extérieur je pense on a toujours été
transparent
je pense qu'on a eu je sais pas combien
d'émissions combien d' images on peut
voir ce qui est on n'a jamais nié qu'ils
avaient une violence qui a un historique
aussi de façon définitive
sauf que on ne peut pas accepter qu'il y
ait de la violence envers nos familles
casino famille là c'est le pal mal fait
les enfants est au sol qui touche ces
enfants là est ce que j'aimerais un jour
avec la télévision c'est que on a aussi
les bonnes choses qu'on réalise dans nos
communautés de vous vous repentez 1 j'ai
assisté à une soirée de reconnaissance
où on ne donnait plus de transferts de
sommes gaieté mais personne dans les
médias où personne n'a parlé de ces
réalités pile jeune fille qui organisait
sa masi j'en avais encore dauger popu
tous les princes aussi il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de démarches pour s'aider
soi-même on parle beaucoup de guérison
mais c'est pour s'aider soi-même
d'ailleurs il y en a beaucoup beaucoup
dans nos communautés mais reste que
comme vous le dites lorsque le chef de
l'état gauche a vécu enlevé dix a
continué plus un travail est un défi à
tous les jours puis moi je fais des
émissions de radio
fait partager des gens je donne
l'information du mieux que je peux
justement pour aider nos gens qui sont
dans cette situation là oui alors vous
l'avez dit ah vous êtes chef de votre
communauté couetil depuis très longtemps
là depuis 1991
il ya eu par contre des moments vous
n'avez pas été chef à l'intérieur de
entre cette période là 1991 et 2020 ah
non j'ai été élu à 91 s'est réuni à
chaque année jusqu'à l'âge mambé ma
trentième année
avec ce mandat donc vous n'avez jamais
laisser votre place à une femme
gg vous avez notre code électoral elle
permet ceux ci on élit deux zones de
conseillers et conseillères sa cédé à
chaque élection il faut que les deux
hommes et deux conseillères d'accord
mais ce sont de leur sert un mot des
femmes ou de femmes et conseillère
passais ce matin j'arrive au poste de
chef oui ça peut être un homme ou une
femme d'ailleurs il ya eu beaucoup dans
les élections beaucoup de femmes qui ont
été présentées à chaque fois j'ai gagné
les élections
je pense quand on y est on est quand
même respectueux envers les femmes ont
leur permet d'être candidate au poste de
chef du shass est chez nous la paix a eu
des chefs aussi des femmes chefs d'un
dans le port au sénat les communautés in
oui alors en fait je vous pose la
question parce que je vais tendre le
micro à isabelle parce que justement on
va parler des femmes qui sont chefs dans
des communautés mais à travers le canada
il y en a pas tant que ça
non il y en a vraiment pas beaucoup on
parle de 14% seulement au canada c'est
vraiment pas beaucoup au poste de chef
donc ses 87 sur une possibilité de six
ans 33 donc on est vraiment loin de là
partent évidemment pendant longtemps
faut savoir que la loi sur les indiens
jusqu'en 1951
oui faisait en sorte qu'une femme ne
pouvait pas accéder au poste de chef ni
même de conseiller ni même le conseiller
dans tout ça c'est relativement récent
oui la première femme chef au canada
c'est dans les années 50 pour une courte
période mais au québec par la suite et
même au canada
installé en 1992 dans ma communauté
jocelyne gros-louis non sa fin quand
même pas tellement longtemps bien sound
aka oui est ce que disait monsieur pied
tâchons de réserver des postes de chef
ou de conseiller pour des femmes
oui c'est la seule communauté qui le
fait de cette façon là alors on les
regarde avec beaucoup d'admiration et
d'envié bien sûr
maintenant au niveau des postes de
conseillers ou conseillères ou d'autres
l'appellerons chef lorsqu'on nomme le
chef le grand chef ça dépend de la
dénomination il ya un peu plus de femmes
dans les communautés mais on est encore
loin de la parité
si on regarde au québec au niveau des
postes de chef sur une possibilité de
quarante et une 41 postes de chef de
grands chefs seulement entre cinq et
sept femmes bonhomme à la donc autour de
la table c'est encore un boys club on
veut se lever quand il s'est beaucoup
d'hommes alentours de l'ata les femmes
choisissent d'autres moyens pour se
faire entendre notamment via bien sûr
l'association des femmes autochtones du
québec via les médias bond on a déjà
parlé ici autour de la table beaucoup de
femmes les deux des articles ou ici donc
ils vont choisir d'autres moyens mais
c'est très difficile à l'intérieur de
ceux de ce système de conseil de bande
oui oui oui oui mais avant avant que la
loi sur les indiens ne soit créée les
femmes avaient une place beaucoup plus
importante
oui dans les communes we also l'humain
traditionnellement que ce soit chez les
héros qu'on y est bien sûr là on se
souvient on a tous entendu parler des
maires de clans wiki donc qui décide et
qui gardait l'harmonie au sein du clan
mais qui aussi ensemble nommé le chef de
la communauté donc ceux du village
oui donc et elle avaient leur mot à dire
dans les décisions ans quand le chef
prenait une mauvaise décision elle se
faisait entendre
oui j'ai les algonquins donc les innu
les naskapis dont les micmacs ecce terra
la femme avait quand même son mot à dire
également dans ce qui se passait quand
l'homme partez à la chasse pendant deux
trois semaines c'est la femme qui
restait aucun ce sont les femmes qui
restent et lloyds prenait quand même les
décisions donc elle avait une place que
la loi sur les indiens au fait en sorte
qu'elles ont perdu qu elles ont perdu qu
elles ont la difficulté à récupérer
oui oui c'est pas évident on aurait aimé
avoir une femme et c'est autour de la
table on devait en avoir une et
finalement elle a été obligée de se
désister
c'est dommage mais on aura l'occasion de
l'entendre éventuellement elle a été
conseillère dans sa communauté c'est
françoise tout à fait
v cogan oui oui je crois que oui et j'ai
eu l'occasion de travailler avec elle
en fait je lui ai enseigné je donne un
cours de gouvernance autochtones au
féminin et j'ai plusieurs femmes élues
autour de la table j'avais des
attikameks aussi j'avais dans des gens
d'un peu partout et ce qu'elle me dise
c'est tout la même chose c'est que c'est
difficile pour une femme de se faire
entendre quand il ya peu une place
peut-être comme un coing jeep de se
faire entendre autour de la table de
faire entendre des préoccupations ou des
besoins qui sont peut-être davantage du
féminin finalement ça veut dire tout ce
qui est comme une santé communautaire
les enfants donc c'est vraiment à ce
niveau locke c'est difficile de ça oui
oui oui
pas parce que vous de votre côté chef
piétacho est-ce que évidemment vous avez
des rencontres avec les autres chefs des
différentes communautés québécoises
est-ce que les exemples que vous mettez
de l'avant est-ce qu'il y en a qui ont
envie d'y répondre là le fait d'avoir
établi cette politique d'avoir des
femmes des hommes au conseil de bande
donc tout le monde peut se présenter est
ce que vous avez réussi à la vendre à
d'autres communautés avec le temps non
j'ai pas je vais pas à vendre mais lui a
jamais écoutés a comme la communauté et
nous la prada à des athlètes qui ont la
même le même code que nous avons à man
show pour s'il faudrait juste validé
mais c'est nous qui l'avons
choisi en assemblée générale avec les
gens de la communauté
et vous ce qui est du poste de chef
c'est comme je le dirai tout est ouvert
aux deux et non je pensais je pas
souvent de ça aux autres communautés
mais je sais pas si ce qui fait aussi
c'est comme vous y le fait que nous on
est quand même on va dire ça jeunes dans
le système mais quelqu'un qui est là
depuis 1867 et 76 ce système là les
comme incrustée c'est un système fédéral
puis à chaque fois tâcher de faire de
changements mais là on te dit ben
et il faut changer la loi mais pour
changer la loi en tout cas c'est pour
d'une évidence lorsqu'on parle de ça
mais nous on veut
vraiment aller répondre pascal attentes
des chefs
il ya aussi des familles je connais bien
monsieur madame jérôme la kiffer trade
rien jérôme oui oui bien bien mais à
notre table le fait aussi c'est qu'on
ait deux représentants hommes et femmes
souvent là un nom de s'interroge bien
jeune une femme d'un certain âge qu'une
jeune c'est quand même bien mais
peut-être qu'on pourrait encore
l'améliorer parce qu'on a des mandats de
3,1 dans la communauté
mais on parle beaucoup de revoir notre
système c'est sûr qu'on est comme coincé
avec le système fédéral mais je pense
qu'on peut faire nous là à l'intérieur
des changements auxquels nous on se sent
à l'aise pour respecter l'ensemble de
l'ensemble des sociétés un mot les
hommes on sent bien dans la boue sa vie
il ya pas si longtemps alors on ne
permettait même pas d'un tel que les
femmes assises vous semblez général dans
certaines communautés la ccg pas si
longtemps mais chez nous d'après moi ce
que je peux voir il ya toujours eu la
représentation de tout le monde
il a semblé ou peut-être même on a
changé le système en 1991 pour ce seul
façon égale avec du comme ça allons voir
avec isabelle comment ça se passe et
comment ça se passe encore celle et
morale parce que vous avez été femme
d'un chef d'une communauté moat donc
vous avez vu tout ça de l'intérieur
absolument c'est le cas de le dire on
était à l'époque au début des années
2000 en 2004 2005 environ et c'était
j'étais femme de chef à la can et
s'attaquer donc canet s'attaquer comme
plusieurs communautés mohawks ghana ok
c'est la même chose le conseil de bande
n'est pas reconnu par l'ensemble de la
population donc déjà là notamment mais
magana voir guillon encore système
parallèle
additionnez oui avec monlibert de cloche
est oui donc il conjugue avec sa canne
et s'attaquer c'est un peu différent
mais il ya quand même une partie de la
population qui n'adhèrent pas à ce
système qu'il considère comme étant des
déshérités finalement jean charles le
disais tout à l'heure de la loi sur les
indiens
oui donc c'est pas facile pour un chef à
ce moment-là de naviguer à travers tout
ça et oui ça a été plutôt difficile à
cette époque là j'ai on a vécu quand on
est une jeune famille on a vécu aussi
des menaces bon par téléphone mais c'est
aussi difficile le rôle de chef dans le
sens que ça demande un effort de 24
heures sur 24
la nuit on recevait des téléphones c'est
autant de s'occuper d'une chicane de
clôture que d'un divorce que devenir
médiateur que de que d'aller rencontrer
la grc que d'aller rencontrer les agents
du ministère des affaires indiennes de
se dépatouiller avec les médias aussi
bien sûr en état au col donc pas très
longtemps après la crise d'oka ailleurs
si l'on put on était en velin dans
l'épisode bojinski bruel avec l'incendié
de la maison tout ça donc c'était jeanne
cabrol qui est elle qui était le
chercheur c'est dans exactement
et donc il y avait eu un incendie du
la station de police également donc on
était vraiment on l'a eu assez de
mesures tout ça c'est bien évidemment
avec la police de cannes et sète oui
exactement tout à fait et donc mais être
chef c'est pas mon brave aulas pour
monsieur piétacho qui est là depuis 1991
comique de l'intérieur c'est vraiment
une mission c'est extraordinaire ce que
ces gens l'enfant et comme disait
monsieur péta chaussée qu'ils ont je
veux pas les mains liées
ils voient les besoins dans la
communauté il aimerait répond il tente
de répondre mieux qu'ils peuvent mais le
système fait en sorte qu'il ya des
programmes et que le ministère des
affaires autochtones décidons mais cette
année c'est la santé qui est une
priorité alors que peut-être que dans
cette communauté la santé va assez bien
aiguillé le logement oui oui oui on
aurait besoin oui dans une autre
communauté c'est peut-être la langue la
culture alors que pau dessous pour soyez
pas de financements dont ils doivent
souvent composer en faire des miracles
et je pense qu'on ne reconnaît pas assez
ce parce que ce sont des gens qui sont
impliqués qui veulent faire des
changements
mais alors comment comment rallier la la
la la portion plus traditionnelle à
votre cause
les gens voient bien le travail que vous
faites et le savent que vous avez les
mains liées jusqu'à d'une certaine façon
la cause de la loi sur les indiens
comment rallier les gens qui sont plus
traditionnelles besoin que sûrement oui
oui avoue chiffres annoncés mais ces
gens là chez nous sont là et je sais
lorsqu'on les rencontre soit en
assemblée générale
je sais je connais leurs discours mais
il ya quand même un minimum de respect
un basque nous on est à ecône is yet
vous savez comme vous utilisez belle l'a
très bien résumé là c'est cette fois je
crie pas et fischer là n'ont cessé pour
ce pas facile la zone communautaire est
allé membres je conseille mais souvent
on le dit c'est bouché non non on est on
est singles annoncé vous vous je
m'adresse à vous mais ces gens là chez
nous là mais je trouve ça c'est sûr j'ai
vécu la période dont il avala que là je
lui ai vu que je suis même allé
rencontrer james dans une telle laval
pendant cette période là tu te poses des
questions c'est assez de défendre les
doit à ses dépens l'échos sur ce sujet
qui intéresse la nation hôte à
communauté est une réalité que
quand je retourne chez nous c'est cette
réalité là auxquels doit faire face et
je pense que ceux qui pensent autrement
que moi moi je suis comme elle a un
produit la plage ici mal est là selon la
loi scellier moi j'y allais parce que
les gemmoises et tu devrais te présenter
comme ma chère parce que dans notre
valise et peut-être une dictature mais
définitivement non moi je cherche mon
père était chef bon grimpeur et
échappement à rien celui qui m'a gardé a
été conseillé a tracé une ligne et comme
on dit mais sauf que c'est les gens qui
apprécient et dos et plus plus plus dur
sera de même passé c'est plus dur parce
qu'il ya des décisions camp auquel on
leur demande et je suis ok parce qu'il
ya un haute autorité a coûté le qui va
dire le contraire mais temps moi je veux
construite 10 maison j'en ai besoin de
58 la wii mais 58 mais là
un financement qui doit y répondre à la
situation qui prévaut dans la communauté
et où je viens c'est comme vous dites là
on est lié on devrait avant n'est normal
hein c'est une demie maisons par année
l'a6 fonction faisait les calculs après
soul is heavy et poulton animateurs
oasis et une demi-année salah et encore
ils ont coupé mais là j'ai dit au
fonctionnel donc je suis venu à
travailler tôt et demi un demi salaire
pendant une année la vienne à la
communauté gay vient nous voir mais
c'est cesser ces situations-là qui qui
sont là puis candelon loire pente et
tout en essayant de défendre des causes
les doigts juste un exemple au niveau
moi je suis très rapidement puisque nous
allons terminer on vous rivaux au niveau
de la défense du golfe saint laurent des
eaux c1 mais il n'y a pas cent qui
s'occupe de ça mais moi je pris par
cette cause parce que si un événement
qui nous arrive du même type que mexique
qui s'y d'angoissé l'allègement des noms
et non c'est pour ça que vous je suis
souvent chez nous au niveau
la promesse ni au niveau international
d'ailleurs je suis à new york en février
pour aller parler à l'unesco au
intéressant on aura sûrement l'occasion
d'en discuter de vous attraper à votre
retour
merci chef piétacho d'avoir consacré
c'est toutes ces minutes là avec nous
c'est vraiment très très apprécié merci
beaucoup
quand même et je vous laisse poursuivre
votre travail auprès de votre communauté
equani cheat je sais que c'est pas
pareil dans toutes les communautés mais
vous avez ya un bel exemple avec vous
d'une communauté qui fonctionne bien qui
est apprécié en fait on voit que le chef
est appréciée merci beaucoup à vous ces
deux marques ont maintenant ou jamais et
merci beaucoup isabelle d'avoir été là
encore une voilée à la semaine prochaine
bien sûr avoue aussi à la semaine
prochaine pour une autre édition d'
espace autochtone en direct au revoir
[Musique]